I thought the saddest thing I heard
through the whole Super Bowl Gary and
John were on the wrap-up show they got
the craps to come by and they even got
my Holmes to come by and they put
Richard on with my Holmes and you
started crying tall dude you are so
[ __ ] on I couldn't control myself
oh yeah I'm gonna play it for you oh I
don't want to hear it oh my god you're
such a [ __ ] weirdo I get emotional
like witness a baby man I'm gonna play
this for you but Richard starts crying
to my homes first of all you're like
Patrick would you done for Kansas and
you gonna bring this Super Bowl and you
don't know what it means for people like
me it means nothing like people like you
you're a guy who got out of Kansas you
work on the Howard Stern Show you live
in Manhattan where did you work in
Manhattan this show isn't based there
you're not typical of a Kansan so when
you tell my home's people like me how
many people you got to hear this listen
to this [ __ ] maniac well I mean he's
just like this amazing ray of hope that
you know what you've brought to Kansas
City is and I'm just probably thinking I
got to get off this show I came in to
have fun you know like this [ __ ]
weird I was crying I'm getting emotional
exert Patrick it's all you've just
brought so much happiness to people like
me and you know Chiefs fans I had so
much fun watching you this year and you
just mean so much to me and all
everybody in Kansas City and all my
friends we have a Chiefs bar here in
Queens New York that we watch from and
we just have such calm rocailles
thinking himself who is this weirdo like
I don't even want to be in Kansas City I
just got you know they hired me and you
just made us so happy this year and I am
so excited for what's to come in the
many years ahead so thank you Patrick
no I appreciate it man I appreciate
everything you said and hopefully we get
that Super Bowl for you here soon yeah I
hope to see you in
Miami a year from NASA yes sure you're
super close with your dad and you had
told me how you guys kind of bond over
the way Patrick plays in his whole story
absolutely I mean my dad got my dad I
was born in 74 so I didn't get to see
the Chiefs
win the Super Bowl in 1970 but my dad
did and my dream is for myself and my
dad to be able to watch the the Chiefs
win the Super Bowl together what's going
on he must have been so happy I wasn't
there alive right I didn't even think
about that
well then to him it's like who's this
old [ __ ] who's crying they asked him if
the guys ever cried in front of him and
he said no and I know that you can make
that happen Patrick and they'll just
thank you man we're gonna get it done
for sure we'll make that happen for sure
I know you will I know you will and
that's why I love you so much man during
this whole time how long is my contract
we'll be out of there [ __ ] baby
you're out of your mind I can't wait I
hope my home's leaves hope my homes go
spike